an important part of your image making
mostly small devices is what you use for
backgrounds or how to view backgrounds
you could make some very interesting
images even more interesting if you
subtly suggest a certain kind of
background that works that's relevant
your selection can really change your
image sometimes you have to be kind of
careful because the background can
overtake what it is that you want to say
and we'll see that in a moment so take
for example this image that I made of a
assemblage of pieces and I took it on a
surface against a white wall which is
what a lot of you do and the issue for
me is that even though you don't think
the viewer sees it the viewer does see
the horizon where the two pieces of
material meet you might say was what's
the big deal well you should start
really getting into the habit of trying
to edit out anything that is ambiguous
or that is not giving the viewer a very
clear view of what it is you want them
to see so it's much better to just keep
a piece of paper handy and just simply
fold it up towards the back and you'll
get yourself a very nice background
without seeing that distracting
horizontal line I really do suggest you
that you start doing these kinds of
things it's easy with such small devices
here's a device that was taken just in
the lab a quick image and once again the
researcher knows what it is to look for
but you cannot expect the first time
viewer to see what you want them to see
and so they do see all the mess behind
it so just take that piece of paper that
we use before and just put the device on
it lean it against the same background
that you had before but this time with
the paper going up hiding that material
in the back you can see a much
clearer device sometimes echoing what it
is that you're looking at it could be
very helpful oh I was asked to take some
images of some copper sulfate crystals
and so I found a piece of copper two
pieces of copper actually and just
suggested the presence of copper in this
material and here with these plastic
shapes that were fabricated in the lab I
just thought it would be fun to put it
against a grid not a very clean grid by
the way this is taken quite a long time
ago but what it did show was sort of
helping to define these shapes and how
those lines were changed when these
plastic pieces were put over it here's
an image I took for book trying to talk
about a drop of water which is very
complicated and what I did was remember
we're using a 105 lens focusing on the
drop so as you probably know by now you
get a very narrow depth of field with
these 105 lenses which is what we wanted
in this case because the background is
blurred the next image shows you the
background I mean it's something I
bought quite a while ago knowing someday
I will use it for a background because I
liked the look of it and I also knew
that with a 105 lens it would become a
whole different thing as you see take a
real hard look at that drop and you'll
see that the drop itself became lens
that has focused the background so it's
a little playful thing that I forgot
what happened but it did but he was a
background totally out of focus that you
want to be out of focus otherwise it
would just be too much of an image on
this one image of a bacillus on in a
petri dish I just decided to layer the
petri dish on a particular plastic blue
and then I put the blue / orange and I
just was having kind of fun on this one
we're showing sketches of the CAD that
was used to make the
use devices and it's just a sketchy like
idea which I like very much I still like
the idea of showing some sort of human
hand to the fabrication of very high
technology I think that we should use
more of these kinds of ideas that's my
point of view and here's another it's a
wafer made into electronic device with
one background and I took the same wafer
put on another background and then again
on another background and changing the
angle a little bit so you actually see a
very different color palette and that's
what I'm talking about it's all related
you make one change in one spot and then
it's going to change your composition or
your point of view it's just ongoing the
permutations for this image we wanted to
show the ability to make these crystals
and I decided to use some weighing paper
against a desk and it just happens that
the light is coming in from the window I
actually used it compositionally and as
part of the background and here we're
seeing material that results into a
powder and again I'm using weighing
paper and make a sort of an interesting
overlay of shapes because it's a pretty
boring picture otherwise I think it's a
little more successful and these are
things are not easy to photograph as I'm
sure you know and on this i use the
reflective quality of glass it might not
be as successful as i thought because
maybe you can't quite tell where the
glass begins and the real slide with
these these are highly hydrophobic
slides that's why you're seeing the
water bubble as it does i don't know
it's something to think about and here I
used I kind of was echoing the shape of
this material how it coils into these
nice scoops and I decided to use a small
table to echo the shape of the naturally
occurring curves
here's an example where I put the device
on stickam just a blue posted onto which
I'm on that I put posted on a black
surface I think this works I think the
next one where I used a crazy background
that I got a card that was kind of fun
it's fun to look at the card but not
with the device on it it's just way way
over the top and too much where the
background just really gets in the way I
needed to take a photograph of this very
small robot flying robot which measures
about one centimeter long and use the
box the plastic box that it arrived in
as part of the composition which I think
Phil's the background in an interesting
way in this image this was a very quick
image that I just made just to see how
what kind of depth of field I was going
to get with these small devices and it
turns out that I sort of liked the
haphazard pneus of this image the
background just was accidental for me it
works maybe not for you but for me it
does backgrounds should be part of your
vocabulary there is no question in my
mind about that